[Musique]
pour se voir les enfants
il ya de l'orage douleur ce soir oui on
dirait nounours alors je reviendrai vite
patron ou le cheval europe hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop
et puis tu lui diras aussi ne t'inquiète
pas un petit pain prenait bonsoir les
enfants ça vous fait drôle de petit ce
soir
mais je n'avais pas les oui on va parler
tous les deux nous nous bien sûr nicolas
on va se parler entre avec moi je te
suis nicolas allons dans la cuisine bien
moi je voulais à trappes
[Musique]
on y collant mon petit non non non c'est
pas gentil tu ne penses pas nous tu nous
oublie tu pars en voyage et puis tu nous
rapporte rien
pauvres petits enfants et béthune nous
écrit pas au haut
et je suis un méchant nous nous sommes
passés gentil avec des amis au long tu
ne peux plus
toujours
[Musique]
apporté je ne voulais pas donner hier
soir car vous étiez coucher mais je ne
vous ai pas oublié tenue
pour nicolas est longue pour pas preneur
c'est quand même gentil non robert
petit garnement
la prison au lit
[Musique]
oh
mais où son tir
en dormez-vous vite vous n'avez pas été
gentil avec moi c'est fini on ne fera
plus jamais de reproche qui tienne
c'est pour toi une sucette
merci le zoo au
oui
la junte allait mieux
fait de boer
la noce
[Musique]
alors nounours lumeau trop lui une
sucette je le vois ce qu'il me patron
est ce qu aux jo les rats en route gros
sentimentale bonne eu des enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents le petit
bourg book
[Musique]
m